هذه محميه الجبال المقدسه
ومتنزهها الوطني في مقاطعه دونيسك
الاوكرانيه في ما مضى
وهي هنا عندما تجلت الحرب بكل قبحها حرب
لا تلقي بالا لحياه البشر ولن يعنيها
كثيرا مصير الشجر
هي من اكبر المحميات الطبيعيه في اوروبا
تعرضت للقذف من القوات الروسيه التي سيطرت
عليها قبل استعادتها من قبل القوات
الاوكرانيه في سبتمبر ايلولا الماضي
من المحميه
الان في القتال ما زال مستمرا حتى ان
اراضي المحميه قصفت قبل يومين ونخشى دخول
الغابه في جزء كبير منها مشروع من الغام
والاولويه الان هي لازاله الالغام على
الجبهات ومن المناطق السكنيه
هذه اللافتات من اشعال النار حفاظا على
الطبيعه لم تلقى اذان المصريه
ويعتقدوا القائمون على المكان ان حرائق
الغابات في معظم خطرها على المحميه التي
توصف برئه اقليم دونباس تبقى اهون بكثير
من تاثيرات تسرب مخلفات الذخائر وما
تحويله من مواد سامه الى التربه
2014 مات كثير من النباتات ولم ينمو اي
شيء لنحو ست سنوات هذه الاشجار التي قد
تبدو لك واقفه اذا لم تعالج بسرعه فستموت
بسبب المواد السامه وهنا السؤال المهم كيف
سيؤثر تدمير الغطاء الاخضر لاكبر دوله
اوروبيه في مناخ القاره
تقول الحكومه الاوكرانيه ان نحو 20% من
محمياتها الطبيعيه تعرضت للضرر وان اكثر
من خمسه ملايين فدان من غابات البلاد قد
احترق جراء الحرب الروسيه
المستمره في علاء اوكرانيا منذ نحو تسعه
اشهر في خضم هذه الحرب قد لا يعلو صوت فوق
صوت المدافع وربما لن يجد العالم الوقت
الكافيه للتوقف عند تداعياتها واخطارها
البيئيه التي قد تتجاوز حدود اوكرانيا